I think Tate's uh because he's a he's
clearly a smart and thoughtful guy and
uh he's quite funny too but uh I think
his miscalculation was he was playing up
a character as comedy as funny people do
I mean we all do it we play up certain
we'll say certain things on this podcast
right now four jokes that are not really
real but if somebody went hey did you
really feel that way I'd be like no you
idiot we're choking around because we're
four guys in a room Boston balls I don't
really think Malik is the black guy yeah
I just said that but the tricky thing
with with Andrew and I think the
miscalculation was his business was tied
to those things being his actual beliefs
and truths he's getting five million a
month for Hustler's University and it's
and it's tied to him actually speaking
these things as truths and I saw him I
think it was on like Pierce Morgan he's
like I wish I could have maybe redone it
or like delivered it in a different way
but the thing is the more salacious you
go the more attention and you get
quicker you get I think he could have
gotten there uh the same place he's at
now just at like a slower trajectory he
would have gotten there but it wouldn't
have been so meteoric but yeah I think
that's really it it's like he can't say
I didn't believe any of that stuff
because then you lose all that money
that's coming in based on those beliefs
do you think he's gonna fight Jake Paul
if I'm him I wouldn't
why because if he loses it kind of loses
the whole stick I don't think he lose
the stick because I think he's like
smart enough to like think of a way
around it like The Bravery of just going
in there I respect any guy who gets in
the ring I mean it's just it's a you
know if you ever if you ever like box or
anything like that it's like it's this
is the real deal like a lot of people
talk about [ __ ] they don't want to get
in there so I respect him for actually
doing that in general but Jake is is a
jake is a beast bro a lot of people
don't want to Jake is a beast Jake will
[ __ ] up most boxers
he will [ __ ] up most MMA guys I mean I
think we've already proven that in a
boxing match
I think he'd be the first person to say
like I'm not beating any of these guys
in MMA this is what their expertise is
but he's taking it seriously and then I
imagine Tate who's probably in his 30s
right maybe 35 36 yeah yeah he probably
hasn't fought in a few years like that
that is like a whole transition in life
to go do something to prove what you
were already a world champion kickboxer
what do you prove by beating beating
Jake maybe you get a Payday maybe it's I
think there's a number amount okay let's
say you get 5 million let's say you get
10 million is it worth it I don't know
what the guy's worth but if you got a
hundred million or whatever maybe he's
saying he got in the bank like is it
worth it for five is it worth it to
train for six months your rotator cuffs
[ __ ] up your eye already has issues
like is that worth it for five or could
you take those six months and apply
yourself to another business and make
five I don't know what would you do I
think you're right I don't I don't think
you should fight him I don't think he
should fight by the way if and I don't
want to take money out of Jake's pocket
because I [ __ ] with Jake I love him you
know what I mean well no I think I think
Jake is uh uh I put them in a top five
best troll [ __ ] talkers in the game it's
uh and he goes up against people above
him and he hangs it's not like he's
calling our people below him bullying he
goes up and he he can go go up against
anybody no I don't think uh Tate wins
here whether he wins or not like okay
let's just say Tate fights and he wins
what are you gonna say
what are you gonna say take Tate fights
and he wins what changes you're a world
champion kickboxer yeah exactly right
but but if but if Jake goes and he wins
what do you think Jake and more
importantly what does Logan say my
younger brother
and I I don't think you do this fight I
don't think it's necessary I think this
whole thing is plenty outside of this I
don't think you do the fight and you're
already coming back like you've seen
listen they're guys who get canceled
yeah they don't have the chops to come
back yeah he's got the chops like he can
speak to
intellectuals and defend himself pretty
well there's some certain things that
they'll kind of like pigeonhole him into
and he's just got to go like all right I
said something was [ __ ] up I shouldn't
have said it but he can hang so all he
needs to do is continue doing what he's
doing now and then he just has to turn
down the dial a few degrees it doesn't
and it's not going to be as funny it's
not going to be as salacious but it
doesn't need to be because he's already
established the name and then he can
continue riding that out he's actually
is interesting things to say he just
said some wild [ __ ] that if he was a
comedian we would all laugh at him and
not question of course okay I had a joke
back in the day that went it was it was
one of the first things that actually
like started my career went viral on
Reddit on on Super Bowl Sunday I
remember it happening and um and it was
um
uh countries that treat women the worst
have the best food and I remember and uh
and and it was this whole long bit about
like like nobody's ever went out to say
like you want to have Canadian tonight
like no whatever it's like the more
women you know you're like stay in the
kitchen the better the food comes out
and this bit this like long crafted bit
I put it out and went viral on Super
Bowl Sunday I'm a comedian if there was
a person who was literally making the
argument that that's how we should treat
women so food tastes better you'd be
like this guy's a [ __ ] psychopath
right and then if they made a lot of
money off of that and they had to stick
to that it's a really awkward position
but when you're a comedian you're going
hey I was just being entertaining and
like playing with things that happened
to be true and are correlated but might
not be like causality and you get away
it's kind of fun I almost wish Tate
could be like dude I'm a comedian but I
also say really kind of insightful
things so we could still get the fun
[ __ ] that's the that's the card of a
comedian you see it's like I almost want
to go do a couple
so with all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people weren't in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks spread
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]